millions of cattle migrate when water
dries up in southern pakistan farmers in
remote districts film it on their phones
as the dry spells are becoming longer
and the movements more frequent
it's a long off-road trek to get to
their villages
with no government support people in the
kohestan region are trying to adapt to
climatic changes around them
for generations people and animals here
have used the same water source
these ponds retained rain water from
surrounding hills
now some non-government organizations
are helping increase their water
retention capacity so when it rains it
lasts a few months
48 reservoirs with some up to 18 feet
deep have helped more than 74 000 people
in this hilly terrain
the indus earth trust says it's used
corporate social responsibility funds
from large corporations and there's no
government assistance to provide water
to villages
bonds like these have helped people
adapt to the changing climate but
they're still angry at the politicians
who represent them saying they only come
here for votes and basic services such
as health education and accessibility
are still non-existent
activists say big land owners are still
underestimating the impact of climate
change with killings and abductions
common here they say it's risky to raise
their voice for basic rights
is there a school building we need
schools hospitals and roads but our most
important necessity is water in about a
month this water will dry up and we'll
have to travel far to get some our
children cry of thirst when we run out
and when pregnant women travel for water
many faint and there's no nearby health
facility
life's become tougher here as yearly
rainfall has dwindled josekar says
during the time of his ancestors water
was plentiful but now it runs out and
many people are forced to migrate
we don't need electricity not even roads
but we are desperate for water for
ourselves and our cattle
ministers say it's not possible to reach
everyone as pakistan is among the top 10
countries most vulnerable to climate
change
pakistan's cash-strapped government says
it's a victim of climate and justice we
estimate it's between
six and fourteen billion dollars a year
that we have to spend because of forced
adaptation it's not a choice we have we
are forced to adapt to climate change
and these
funds come come out of our priorities
out of health out of education out of
governance so i think this is the area
where
the world needs to wake up because
this injustice cannot continue
with some help people are adapting
harnessing solar energy has meant
there's been reverse migration in some
villages
having electricity is like a miracle for
the vizier family they can finally work
after daylight hours
we have electricity now and the children
can study but we still have no water or
gas so we have to carry water on our
heads but despite all this some of our
villagers have returned as there is
electricity here
small scalable projects can be adapted
for larger communities if there's
political will and money
but pakistan's water challenges are
complex multifaceted and time is running
out to address them
osama bin laden
southern pakistan